talk to me is leaving audiences with
lots of questions not the kids possessed
by Spirits or demons what do those
beings want and what's the deal with the
kangaroo
talk to me
talk to me opens with Cole at a party
searching for his brother Duckie who's
been acting strangely Cole yells at the
party goers for filming duckett's
freakout but Duckett ends at defense by
stabbing his brother and then himself
after this shocking intro the movie
shifts to Mia she and her friends play
with a supposed psychics and bombed hand
that grants those who hold it and say
talk to me then I let you in a very
special High via Spirit possession
however the catchers at The Possession
has to be cut off by letting go of the
hand and blowing out the candle within
90 seconds any longer and things tend to
get out of control Mia goes a bit over
the time limit during her possession
which makes us see things long after she
stopped holding the hand and able to
resist the euphoric high that the hand
offers Mira and her best friend Jade
hosts a get-together with the kids from
school who own the hand things get real
when Mia allows Jay's little brother
Riley to take his turn with the hand
against the wishes of his sister it goes
fine at first but then Mia encourages
him to stay possessed for longer than
the allotted time after she realizes
he's seems inhabited by the spirit of
her beloved mom this causes a possessed
Riley to try to destroy himself and
leaves an increasingly possessed mere on
a path to destruction so what happened
to Mia's mom we learned early on from
Mia that she overdosed on sleeping pills
and couldn't be saved in time because
she was in a locked room it's implied
that it was suicide but Mia isn't
certain nonetheless Mia's grief isolates
her from friends and family who love and
feel for her birds have moved on with
their lives her dad and friends don't
know how to handle her depression and
neither does Mia that's my mom's
Remembrance Day
I just want to forget about it that is
until she gets her mitts on the hand as
previously mentioned she makes supposed
contact with her mother during Riley's
possession this causes her to become
obsessed with the hand and use it to
find out the truth about what happened
to her mom that's Mia's addiction to the
hand grows so do the consequences of
using it Mia sees more of her mom but
leaves herself open to being possessed
by all manner of demons even though the
hand-helped Mia feel less alone at first
by the end of talk to me it has taken
over her life and endangered those of
her friends and family mere shift from
the hero of the movie to its fearsome
killer is made possible because in her
grief Mia lets the wrong ones in those
demons take her and almost get her for
good in the end not a lot is known about
the embalmed hand but we do learn that
if you die while possessed the demons
will have you forever at the end of the
movie Riley seems right on track for
life in Eternal demon hell so does Mia
the kids find Cold who tells them the
safest bet for Riley is to wait the
demons out but Mia's getting other
information Mia's mom tells her that her
father is an impersonator leading
possessed Mia to accidentally stop him
thinking she's killed her father and
desperate to free Riley from his
possession Mia tricks Jade into leaving
her alone with Riley the false maternal
Spirit convinces her that if Riley dies
he will be at peace and she can take
care of him it looks like Mir is going
to kill Riley into the spirit vision of
the bloody kangaroo from the beginning
of the movie shows up in the hospital
Jade discovers Mia's dad then raises at
a hospital in time to see Mia push
Riley's wheelchair up to the highway
just when we think she's gonna push
Riley out into the oncoming traffic Mia
throws herself onto the road instead at
first it looks like she survived demon
free however as she walks through the
hospital and sees that now healed Riley
with his family and sees her father also
recovered she realizes she's dead she
heads towards a small light for an
outstretched hand awaits belonging to
one of the many Greek partyers the final
moment shows Mia on the other side of
the talk to me handshake the spirit side
at face value the end of talk to me
means Mia shook the curse the same way
Duckett did in the opening of the movie
She ended the curse by ending herself
but just like was duckett's
self-destruction the cursed buck doesn't
truly stop there even if Mia sacrifice
ultimately ended the immediate effects
of the curse the fact that she has a
waking experience of the spirit world as
a ghost herself along with the fact that
the hand ends up in Greece means there's
always going to be more to this story as
long as a curse and bombed hand still
exists it seems likely to keep being
passed to other groups of friends and
partyers looking for a new high a higher
follow account or even a sweet bit of
relief from grief
did the hand feel like
felt amazing so do spiritual demons
haunt the hand sometimes the possessions
seem friendly sometimes they're making
out with dogs and sometimes has a bloody
red pit full of demons facing on the
Flesh of the innocent Riley so which is
it there are flickers of both spirits
and demons in the world the kids access
with a hand for a moment in each
possession there appears to be a real
Spirit present but then the spirits can
become demonic if someone remains
possessed for too long what happens
after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
for instance when Riley is first
possessed Mia's mum's Spirit seems
genuine all she wants to do is ask her
daughter's forgiveness and say she loves
her but after Riley goes over time any
spirit that appears through him seems
evil throughout the movie mere flickers
between seeing helpful Spirits such as
the little girl on Riley's bed to Demons
like her mom and dad there's also the
aforementioned demon Buffet Dimension
she Witnesses when she tries to free
Riley from limbo in the hospital this
law isn't ever fully fleshed out in the
movie which doesn't matter when you
watch it but the confusion helps muddy
the waters for Mia as she desperately
follows her grief into hell it's a
time-honored tradition in possession
films for demons to mess with people
either because the humans mess with them
first or because demons want what demons
want which is to face on an endless
Buffet of human Souls talk to me never
Dives too deeply into the lore of why
demons do what they do but it's a little
from column A and the little from column
B when it comes to what they want from
Mia but as we mentioned earlier if she
stays too long or dies while possessed
the demons get her forever for whatever
reason Mia summons her spirits through
the hand then she breaks the rules and
makes Riley stay too long under the
possessive state so now the demons want
their human bodies and eternal Souls but
if we open the door but we didn't shut
up it's a real you break it you buy it
possession philosophy if Mia didn't get
greedy maybe she and Riley could have
just sung more songs together in the car
Mia sees a dying kangaroo in the
beginning that comes back to literally
haunt her in the end however unlike her
demonic mother figure this animal's
ghost isn't interested in possessing me
as mortal Soul instead the kangaroo
wants to save it in the beginning of the
movie Mia and Riley see a wounded
Kangaroo on the side of the road even
though the animal is struggling and in
pain Mia is unable to put it out of its
misery maybe Mia sees some of her own
struggle in the kangaroo or perhaps
she's just grossed out by the idea of
killing it herself to show some mercy
either way she ultimately drives away
and leaves the animal to struggle but in
the ending of talk to me Mia sees a
bloody kangaroo again the spirit version
this time the sight of it right before
she would otherwise kill Riley seems to
strike a chord with her the bloody
kangaroos a reminder of her humanity and
it literally leads the way for Mia to
withdraw from the Demon's clutches long
enough to save Riley from herself and
possibly to save her own soul those of
us who spend a lot of time watching
horror movies know that a great majority
of them don't particularly hit us with
all the feels or often than not it's all
about Thrills scares and Gore well talk
to me surely has a fair share of these
things it also reaches deeper and
presents us with an actual character
that we can identify with and feel for
Mia's grief is seen as a nuisance to her
friends and especially her father who
lies about her mom's death in a
misguided attempt to protect her she's
awkward with Jade's family uncomfortable
at home and feels desperately alone
except for the big sister Dynamics she
has with Riley he's a sweet kid stuck
between being a child and a teenager and
Mia is the only person in his life who
sees him on his own terms some of it
makes the ending all the more poignant
heart racing and Grim that Mia can save
or destroy both of their lives with
their choices but did Mia deserve even
more pain than she was dealing with in
the first place the end of talk to me
gives mere one hero moment but still
leaves her lust in the dark she could
have grown to her grief with Riley but
instead she's trapped in limbo making
the occasion Escape only for haunted
party treks knowing that the hand goes
on to claim more victims like Mia and
ducat it's a Twist of the knife and the
real emotional knuckle sandwich viewers
are left with many questions at the end
of the movie how much time has passed
between Mia's death and the first time
she's summoned by the Greek party as is
Mia going to be able to communicate with
anyone in any meaningful way ever again
or Mia be a destructive force if she
possesses a human body or she walked the
metaphorical path of the helpful bloody
kangaroo for someone else down the line
the directors have talked to me twin
brothers Danny and Michael Filippo want
to leave the ending up to the audience
to determine Dany told deserto we just
want for people to have their own
interpretations and be able to have that
conversation but all the clues are there
everything's planted but we really don't
want to spell things spell anything out
while the movie doesn't hand its
audience any clear-cut message the
directors acknowledge that the film
seems extend from their own personal
experiences Michael told dazed severe
depression runs in her family her
grandmother took her own life and our
mum struggles with her there's the idea
of inheriting it are we going to be
depressed in that way as well Danny
agrees saying I was tapping into things
that scared me personally I can't really
pinpoint what the film is about because
it's expressing so many different things
talk to me stands on its own as a
self-contained horror movie but could
his world get Revisited we still have a
lot of questions calls seem to know more
about the possession even after his
brother Duckett died did he do his
research after the loss is Riley doing
research on Mia's loss is anyone going
to try and summon her from the dead
daddy told Roger ebert.com even when
we're writing the first film we were
writing scenes for a sequel Michael
agreed saying we have barely scratched
the surface of that world and so the
idea of doing talk to me would be very
exciting elaborating on the possibility
of extending the story in the future
Danny told deserto we have an entire
mythology Bible that we don't really
even touch on in the film that explains
everything from like where the hand came
from and there's like little Clues
hidden on the hand and little seeds that
we planted in the same interview Michael
joked we're looking forward to talk to
me to talk to me in space well it might
be a minute before we get to The
Conjuring levels of the talk to me
franchise count us in for talk to me
talk to the Hun
foreign